oh I just sneeze
yeah that's like one of the first times
in my life I've ever seen it on camera
and you know and it like tickles in the
back of your brain and you feel your
whole soul leave your nostril that was
great
oh I was soothing alright people
watching on you - that's the Bleacher
Report Channel the left go show you
could tell I'm wearing the same clothes
those listening at home that's right I'm
using the same voice where I recorded
podcast last week I kind of already told
you this with the algae Crumpler episode
and now my main man Austin Hooper I'm
wearing the same things I'm talking the
same way but I'm still on vacation I
hope y'all are still eating like a homie
I hope you guys still holding yourself
accountable I hope that like you know
that time at like 10 o'clock at night
where you ate really good know you
really did was drink a lot of water and
you feel that part of your stomach and
you're like that's the feeling of me
getting healthy lean into that leena
that I know some of y'all had a piece of
pizza for lunch that's okay we're going
broccoli no pressure though do whatever
it needs to be done I'm riding with you
my prayer is that I'm still healthy I'm
gonna be all my couch
kicking it so if you need if you need
inspiration if you're going through a
struggle if you're out on a Thursday
night and you got a plate full of nachos
that your friend run is just swinging
that cheese in front of your dome piece
hit up the DMS say bro help me and I'm
gonna say [ __ ] run [ __ ] those nachos we
got this okay we're closing in the
number was 33 I can't do math right now
it's probably somewhere in the 20s or a
third of the way there let's do this now
I know that the predictions that I made
on Tuesday if they haven't come true
they're coming true today okay but guess
what
the crystal balls back I have three more
left go Dominus for you three guarantees
that I know we're gonna happen and I'm
doing it well in advance Nick show them
that computer screen
Wednesday May 22nd 247 oh seven oh eight
oh nine and ten and back to me so as you
can tell I've recorded both podcasts and
rows on the same day but that's what we
call efficiency pay beeps I don't know I
was gonna cause I'm gonna call you pants
but again if I'm gonna tell the future I
need two things I need the crystal ball
and I need my chakra music Nick I see
the number 33 zero
I see strength I see motivation I see
best there it is
you just heard it a 30 year plus player
age wise in the NFL will tell people
that he is in the best shape of his life
I just saw it I can't tell if it's
offensive or defensive yet it mm I don't
know might be a special teams but
someone in their 30s will say quote I'm
in the best shape of my life very
confident about that interesting make
sure you check your lifelines okay Nick
Wow
really Wow interesting this is not on
the field this is on social media
it's quite the back and forth a wide
receiver will respond to a hater on
social media but then used the crying
laughing emoji to cover up the fact that
he was butthurt interesting dropping
passes the haters will come out that
response is gonna be brutal hmm if I had
to guess who it was gonna be God I'm
hoping it's him Tonio Brown I don't know
if you guys saw this juju came out last
week and said Oh a Antonio only made
himself available once a week I'm here
whenever you want a slippery slope juju
you're 22 years old be careful what you
wish for cuz that's gonna get not great
anyway one more and it's a big one I can
feel it in my loins in the plums
I feel wings daenerys jog on it's
majestic
the wingspan the fire
oh this isn't just any dragon Davis
[ __ ] Webb the dragon will return as
all the eyes will be on Sam Darnell the
wings of Davis the dragon Webb will
return there will be stories there will
be binders there will be motivation
there will be energy the return of Davis
Webb is upon us you cannot hide or run
King's Landing will seem like a vacation
compared to the streets of New York as
Davis Webb returns to your newspaper
slash Internet slash app slash however
you consume NFL media slash podcast
slash TV shows slash Instagram stories
the Dragon returns six for six guys
feeling really confident almost as
confident as our next guest his name is
Austin Hooper he comes from Cali he
stayed for an entire summer and worked
out with Matt Ryan have one of the best
years of his career made the Pro Bowl
last season and now he's sitting on a
couch talking to me how the mighty have
fallen
hit up Austin Hooper on social tell me
is the [ __ ] man and I don't even need
you to hear at first because I'm telling
you you're gonna like it here is the
conversation with myself and Austin
Hooper he's the guy sitting next to me
right now
Austin Hooper Atlanta [ __ ] Falcons
good for you to be the reason was I
think I read a story that you were
sleeping at Matt Ryan's house is that
true completely incorrect but I was
working with him a lot but then that
story come out I register where you guys
were like together all the time we were
together a lot okay and when it's
bedtime will you go down to my brother's
apartment no way I'll see you tomorrow
what what happened last offseason that
you guys said let's do this the whole
so it all started a Matt Matt's wife
Sarah was pregnant with their twins at
the time some knowing he wasn't gonna be
able to spend as much time on the west
coast
up until summers when we moved it over
the west coast but knowing his wife was
here to be with ya doctor and her ob/gyn
and all that good stuff I figured you
know what everyone shooting off to the
Bahamas Europe wherever Wright's
offseason this is your few months of
freedom do right as you wish I was like
all right no one's gonna be here this
would be a great opportunity to just
spend time with max I mean I've said it
before I say again I mean the
relationship between a route runner and
the quarterback is huge I mean it's not
so much like how crispy your routes are
how good your release game is the way
you put that right foot that's what he
needs to release exactly nonverbal
communication he knows the way my body
moves like the subtlest little drop in
my hips or this triggers like after
hundreds of reps like him just watching
me around running routes one on one he
knows you know my body mechanics so just
helps a lot on what is it so like you
probably thought you had a good
connection with a beforehand right like
before the summer of working out all the
time we were coworkers at that point I
would say like you know I mean he's been
you told people you know I mean like I
came in his 21 year old rookie I mean I
you know I wasn't in his you know yeah I
just you know speak when spoken to is
more of what you kind of do is you know
try to figure it out on your own or get
you know your ass toss a couple times
and figure it out that way so I mean it
was a good opportunity going into what
shoot going into this past year where I
was just like alright I need to take a
deeper dive and spend more time with the
man and understand like what his
expectations are cuz I mean during the
season as you know there's so much stuff
going on especially as a quarterback
like you have to spit out twenty word
play cause yeah there's so much and
peccatis just actually like I don't
really see you up until we hit the
practice field other than in passing a
breakfast or something so you do realize
though that like fans like myself think
that you guys are like sleeping over
each other's houses oh yeah no no no
it's way different than college it's way
different people actually have like
wives and kids and stuff where it's like
I love you but I'll see you tomorrow for
tea yeah like I'm beating my family for
this short amount of time what part of
the summer
did you realize oh [ __ ] we're building
something I'll probably say about two
weeks in when we were in
so Matt Matt Matt Matt's down there in
Orange County who trained out of Golden
West junior college out in Huntington so
about two weeks and I really realize
like you know this
we built upon a couple months we did pre
OTAs and then I just saw the difference
in terms of you know just how many balls
not show that we're connecting because
the balls were there but just
understanding like how much quicker it
is like soon as my head turns around
it's there you could play like the
comfortability with me and him with just
continue to grow so you gotta put all
that work you get the training camp
mm-hm and you're seeing a lot of people
for the first time yeah I mean yeah
could other people notice the difference
in the connection to I mean you have to
ask them I wouldn't know I mean I guess
the coaches I mean like your tight end
coach wasn't coming yeah no I mean my
tight end coach for sure like those who
really was attending weight Harmon was
on now with the Denver Broncos eternally
grateful for Wade he got me as a 21 year
old little punk who thought he knew more
than he did and he he brought me along
so I'm you know I'm eternally grateful
I've always heard a lion coaches are
hilarious I don't know what the the
typical mantra is for a tight ends coach
well
tight ends coaches are like they're
their differences half of them either
come from the receiver world half them
come from the o-line world so you're
like they're getting a diva or or like a
cow yeah so I took I got luckily Wade
was a former offensive line assistant
with the Falcons before become the tight
ends coach so yeah we got a we've got a
lot good wholesome yeah got a lot of
that good ol I'm in banter going on yeah
you know we call it a fun board because
you know we don't we don't do fines in
the room it's completely illegal so it's
fun room yeah yeah so play with monopoly
money it's not real never real never
real no paper money yeah exactly
and then the season started and could
you feel the difference because it the
connection was evident to me absolutely
just get more looks
I mean it's evident by just how many
more ops opportunities you can get and
I'm just understanding that all right in
this situation Matt's brain thinks right
this right so I got saved my you know if
I know in the way Matt thinks versus
this specific look I need use my best
stuff right here your bears performance
was two years ago or yeah this first guy
in my second season
so the thing about you was I always seen
the spark you know I mean like there are
always games like the Bears game where
it's like I'm gonna catch it turn go for
another 40 like all that like the great
it was the consistency yeah and then
this year it was every freakin game
which had to feel like yeah well no I
mean that was the biggest testament for
me the biggest challenge for me and uh
you know III did my best to rise up to
that challenge because there are a lot
of people who I mean it's all on me like
I there were some times where I wasn't
consistent I admit to that and it's just
like you know what just about yeah
growing pains and League being you know
22 so I mean I grew up a little more I
mean I'm still no way shape or form
haven't figured it out I guess found
stuff has worked for me so far and just
trying to build on it you're a pro
bowler though yeah I snuck my bat snuck
in there yes well uninvited guest
how about Zach Ertz yeah eggs agar it's
taken some time off how did it what what
is it like now to like have that title
next to it because not everyone people
can play a whole career or not yeah no I
mean Adams crazy I mean I you know as a
as a competitive person I mean you
always try to aspire for that but is it
always tangible like I don't know so I
just took it week by week just try to
put my best self out there and at the
endless season I was like well we'll see
how it all shakes out and luckily she
luckily I snuck in there so I mean
there's something great I get put next
to my name forever and no one can take
it away from me I thought that this year
for Matt was Matt's best year I would
even say maybe I would say it's it might
be better than what he did in 2015 and I
know that was like the record-breaking
year we 16 2016 with Kyle Shannon and
the main reason is I thought there was
more asked of him this year and I think
I think the Kyle Shanahan offense is
incredible because it puts people in
position to succeed I agree and but this
year he looked better physically he
looked better controlling the offense
like and it doesn't sound like I'm crazy
about this no I mean this was a second I
mean this past year was the second year
with Sarkisian so I mean the rapport
between the play caller in the
quarterback I mean not saying it was bad
before in any way shape or form but just
unroll think how each other thinks and
knowing in what situation what do I
expect before I hear a voice in the
my helmet telling me so I already have
that five ten seconds where I'm already
thinking about okay was the defense man
what matchups what like what guy I was
trying to give you credit that maybe you
working out with him in the offseason
I appreciate you try and throw me a bone
but I'm getting called out by my
teammates if I just blatantly just yeah
where did you grow up I grew up in the
East Bay in Bay Area in Northern
California a little town called San
Ramon cuz I'm sitting here and I'm doing
this interview and I'm going man he's
got too much Cali bro in him to be a
Georgia kid yeah I get that and then
when I go back home people say you sound
like you're from the south when I come
down here the people say you sound like
you're from the will I got a home man
with no flag yeah yeah it's tough damn
what was it like growing up in Cali like
where you grew up I loved it I mean the
weather was and you grew up like when I
Niners fan I mean I didn't really watch
a whole lot of pro ball but if I did I'd
watch both the bay area - yes I mean the
Raiders I was grown up they were rolling
up until Rich Gannon went into a tough
guy in a preseason game and then it kind
of all went down from there then we
drafted got number one overall it didn't
really where it didn't work out too well
and the Niners were kind of in you know
the 500 ball club area up and tell us in
high school journey yeah about years and
then they that sound like you grew up a
Raider fan so that my thing is athletes
they they give up their allegiances and
you're a team the fan of who you play
with the team that drafted ya because
your hometown team didn't so it's like
the team who pays your mortgage is it
different though to face that team like
does that feel have you had a chance to
face the Raiders yeah in Oakland on the
baseball field
it was awesome [ __ ] on the baseball
field I say go you don't fall on the
dirt I don't go out every game warmups
and teach myself how to run routes on
dirt because there's a reason why
baseball players use metal spikes to get
traction
take me back though to like ten year old
Austin Hooper and thinking about playing
on that field
[ __ ] a dream and then after it would go
to Ace games we've got A's games there
in the middle of the week and at the end
Louie check out some Raiders game so I
mean just you know it's like 1012 miles
from the house
right it's just the Eastbay team and
then you fast forward and you're
actually out there yeah it was pretty
surreal moment I had like you know a
bunch of family and friends that's kind
of like the you know culmination of
everything seeing my all my family and
friends in the Raiders stadium
in the black hole see me out there yowsa
I was a completely unknown rookie I
believe that was the second or third
gamely or something like that so I mean
you make a play yeah I'd like three
catches for 85 yards I mean they just
didn't even look at me they're like who
else is risk yeah just yeah let the air
cover this kid I was like all right Wow
catch a seam and run so I was uh I was
very grateful to do them from what's
really funny to with like parents and
stuff when you achieve things is they're
proud of you all the time but there are
certain things that happen that they
become kinder mom is proud of you all
the time your dad your dad in certain
moments would be like you know what son
you did that yeah and that's why you got
to love your father cuz he's gonna keep
it real with you all the [ __ ] to your
mom your mom's gonna tell you what you
want to hear and want to try to protect
you so much I mean that's what moms like
your dad's just gonna tell you though
tell you the truth yeah he's gonna tell
you that oh the amount of times I get
that a basketball game I'll be like why
didn't you box out that one time Oh 100%
it doesn't matter if you scored 20
points I believe what what about that
one player when you whipped on that
block that's posh you see shout-out to
Bruce right shout out Mike right here
nice the other thing though it's like I
I've been able to be in media now for a
while I've done like TV before but my
grandma does not understand social media
and she doesn't understand that like I
could be on Bleacher Report and more
people could see that than someone that
does Philadelphia television like that
doesn't make sense to her so for me I
still an AOL email to understand oh wow
she's really awesome yeah I know she
talks to who knocks on her door and who
knows her phone number that's my grandma
so when I did the Rising Stars game on
TV and she saw me all the fact that it
was in that box on the wall I knew that
I had done everything that I needed to
do and that's what it sounds like with
the Raiders where it's like yeah you're
in the NFL and it's amazing but in that
place that
had to feel like nazy yeah be able to go
back home and actually play in front of
you know your high school friends your
family your extended family friends
everybody was there so I mean it was
just a special moment that we all got to
share together were there any other
local kids that you grew up with that
that had a chance that you were
competing with that even got to this
level anyone from well I mean Earth's
Hertz went to high school a couple
cities over I mean it's a little bit
older than me but that was like the tide
in who I grew up like you know that was
a guy he wants to Stanford and I kind of
followed in his footsteps a little bit
and kind of jersey exchange after week
one last year there was no Jersey
exchange she was getting mobbed I just
Daft him up real quick yeah and got out
of there banged up my knee pretty good
so I wasn't really worried about the
Jersey exchange I had to get all the
swelling out of my knee is okay that I'm
an Eagles fan
you'd be a fan of everything okay cool I
just I I firmly believe that the reason
we won the Super Bowl is not just
because of Nick Foles is also because of
kion O'Neal's knee I believe that you
guys were beating the [ __ ] out of that
was the most physical game I've ever
played in like that game was like I
played in playoff games I played in a
Super Bowl like that game was like
personal like that was like an O circa
Oh 400 you know whatever Jay old school
Jon Gruden smashing out team why do you
think guys to that level team just
obviously don't I just think it was just
the fact that the year before they sent
hmm that's a really good question I
don't know I just feel like oh finish
what you were just saying what are they
I'm a little outlet on like I was
thinking this past year the opening
season game oh you're saying that's the
most physical game yes I was up speaking
out turn a little bit because they
knocked us out of the playoffs and like
we beat the crap out of each other and
then that opening season game when Keanu
went down yes but what I was saying
about Keanu Neal's new is this you guys
were beating the crap out of the Eagles
in the first half Nick Foles throws a
duck across the middle Kiana Neal tries
to pick it off but as oh yeah I remember
that
and it banged off his knee and then
Aguilar caught it and they got a field
goal and ever since the pass went off
his knee Nick Foles was lights out in
the second half they played really well
late
out against the Vikings and he was
lights out against the Patriots so I
give Keanu's knee all of the credit and
the gala terian name yeah it's now I
mean what what one play doesn't make or
break a game we dropped a couple picks I
mean I made some mistakes everything's
just like everybody else yeah I mean one
play doesn't mean that first game of the
year everybody was going down there were
so many injuries but it was telling you
Adam that was the most physical game
I've ever played in like wow they
knocked us out of the playoffs on their
way to winning the Super Bowl yeah a
champion saw I mean there that game was
very personal and they had a lot to
prove because all you hear is if you you
know if you lose Super Bowl have you
crumble and if you want it can you
sustain it so I mean both teams had a
lot to prove they are both these
programs diminish are they drown can
they still compete and you had just gone
through that the year before yeah I mean
my rookie year went all the way to the
ship and then second year we went to the
second round of playoffs where we lost
to your Eagles and then this past year
we didn't hit the are you fully over I
mean to go to that is what it is
yeah I don't know one guy like my dad
told me something you know said son the
Sun will rise in the morning alway and
you can toys yeah I mean I made my peace
with it cuz I mean all you can do is be
pissed off and just think about the past
or you can just you know what forget it
we lost the game we were up we had
plenty of chances to put them away yeah
did it so it's like credit to them
because I mean we're whooping their ass
for a good part of the game yeah and
then Tom Brady and Belichick found a way
I think the biggest thing Adam then now
let people realize is halftime for
regular season games it's 12 minutes
halftime of the Super Bowl is like 35 to
figure out who's that gaga was out there
doing like your whole second and third
album like I remember here's what here's
what we did like the first 15 minutes
you were not allowed to talk to a coach
a coaches not allowed to talk to you of
halftime correct so sit down see just
later like 40 minutes like 12 minutes
you're in day with okay we're doing this
as this is this yeah so I mean Quinn's
been a Jew 22 in Seattle so up until
that point he went to the three of the
last four Super Bowls so so he totally
knew that he understands the format so
he's like you know what let's do this
first 15 minutes you don't talk to us
going and watch film we're gonna figure
out what they're doing absolutely and
offensively and you guys chill out foam
roll stretch hydrate you actually have
time to grab an IV if you need in one
and do whatever then after that all
right we sit back lock back in we're
gonna do another ten minutes of coaches
and players together we're gonna go over
our first you know 15 going on second
half and vice versa and then the next
remaining time we're gonna do a little
we got to warm up again you're sitting
in cold for like 40 minutes so you know
do a little dynamic effort warm up in
the locker room and your pads jumping
around go out so meanwhile I'm till that
point I ran like 26 or 28 plays so Bella
checks in there for half hour just like
okay I'm starting to read the splits
doing the clicker with us exactly like
he's like I'm deciphering this
Shanahan's da vinci code i'm figuring
out exactly okay they're attacking this
player yes they're finding success when
we run out of these fronts when we use
these fronts they go what's incredible
is you guys started the second half and
you still drove down the field and Tevin
Coleman got that touch yo know we came
out the gates huh didn't eat like no
because Kyle is such a mind that he's
one of the few offensive coaches that I
think can go against Belichick and know
that Belichick is gonna adjust and know
how to adjust to his adjustment a
hundred percent like those I believe
that was one of the greatest
cat-and-mouse like back and forth like I
mean I was a rookie I didn't know my ass
from my elbow I just knew it was too you
know one historic coach and one coach
who's you know really good OC I didn't
know any better I elaborate is like 34
points per game against Belichick ya
know like four games and he's so
paranoid Slyke it's like look man I know
we're at the hotel but you have any [ __ ]
don't throw it out here I swear to god
dude
the maid will send it to Belichick I'm
just like okay
oh he's not lying no no no yeah I know
so bellas artes more Ravens when they
would go to New England would suite the
locker room for bugs they would like
unless some serious FBI no no [ __ ]
yeah because the true thing is is it's
that's the mystique of Belichick is that
he must be doing something other than
just coaching but the true thing is
nobody works harder than that
[ __ ] you know this about the NFL I
don't think so there are people that
just work harder than everybody else
yeah and coaching is not created equal
dan Quinn it's not blessed mercy they're
like oh wait
when I hear players call EPL us like
coaches you get four hours of sleep
tonight players
you better get nine tonight I'm just
looking at the coaches like have you
loans last time you seen your family
they're like man they're in season it's
a grind I'm like I mean during hard
knocks last year fossil the special
teams coach of the rams maybe he slept
in the office like every day most
coaches do so I mean what are you gonna
do drive a half-hour sleep for three
hours wake up you know grab a morning
coffee brush your teeth drive another
half hours like you know what I'm
already running on dangerously low
amounts of sleep let's cut out the
middleman I got a toothbrush in my
drawer I got a pillow underneath my desk
and a sleeping bag let's get it but yet
fans don't realize that fans don't
understand like no I mean I think
there's the biggest divide between what
goes into a sport and what fans think I
think NFL is the biggest divide no cuz I
mean you play one or two years in
varsity high school football you think
you know what's happening just because
you play Madden in fantasy football you
think you know what's happening but I
mean I I assure you there's a lot of
factors that go into play that not even
the media will even hint at or the you
know shoot blind in the dark and say
some completely because they just went
and looked at an analytics website that
told them if you're good or bad yeah I
know you look into some computer
algorithm then you know all right I know
what's immediately in the conveyer of
all football knowledge it's it's funny
the way that I try and talk about
football with this show is I am a fan
and I am trying to learn as much as I
can and through that so our players
respect you you don't come out here like
I appreciate that I know what's going on
you're come out here is now positive
like look man like you know what my
theory is for the draft and this is
probably gonna come out after the draft
this is how I'm approaching the draft I
am [ __ ] done with arguing with people
about if a guy's gonna be good or not
and no one has any idea like I watch NFL
Network and I watch the ESPN the ESP oh
I said that and they'll be like I like
him more than him guess what if this guy
goes to the Patriots and this guy
to a teen that's maybe not that good
like that could change their entire
careers so like why are we having these
arguments about kids yeah if I want to
watch guys argue I'll turn on Steven and
skip yeah like I'd rather see something
more informative and right but what I'm
doing this year is I'm just gonna wait
until every guy goes on a team and then
I'm gonna watch them in pre-season and
then I'm gonna watch them and I'll know
if they're good or not yeah I mean
you'll get an idea I mean it definitely
takes you know different players you're
on a different timeline usually she'll
understand okay how is he being used in
the system what did you they asked him
to specifically do like tight ends
easiest one like is he out there on
first down right okay so you better be
out there and third down right so that
one's kind of more transparent positions
where's quarterback like how the hell
knows yeah you did it's yeah you're
shooting dark yeah I mean the learning
curve in that one is so steep do it I
think it's a huge benefit to get drafted
later the only thing that sucks is the
millions in the beginning of your
contract but NFL players it's the second
and third contracts god bless you get a
third the second contract is everything
yeah so I'd rather go to a good team
another thing too if you're at the
bottom of the first round you'd rather
almost be a high second-round absolutely
get rid of that extra year on the
contract Lee because the the difference
between the bottom of the first and top
of the second is like what were the
other tight ends in your draft Hunter
Henry was the first one off the board in
the second round I was the second one in
the third round
Nick fin net was right behind me you
were the second one and you were the
third round middle of the third there
might be three and tight ends were dead
for like three couple of years before I
mean the top guy the year before I think
was max Williams and he went 2nd round a
beautiful second round in Baltimore yeah
our exes in this first name which means
he's very extreme ya know he's a hell of
a special teams player I've seen what
about when you see teams like Baltimore
that plays for tight ends in a game I
mean that's their styles yeah mouths we
want to control the clock run the
football give our defense a risk is
historically that organization has been
built on defense so I mean you got your
big 270-pound edge setters some time to
recuperate your big 330-pound nose
tackle brain and Williams
recuperate - because I mean that's the
thing that's why I like they're a great
team but if they ever get in the
shootout stuff has there ever been a
time where an OC Kyle does not do this
where an OC has lined you up on to block
a pass rusher by yourself it's all the
time.i it's one of the biggest it's one
of my biggest pet peeves in the NFL is
when a coach circles a tight end and
goes and you're gonna block Von Miller
yeah meanwhile you're looking at the guy
next year like why are you paying this
guy like X amount of year like what do
you expect me to do like my thing like a
pass I try keep your hands tight and
just Matt you better get it out in less
than three dude like I'm just getting in
the what was your biggest oh [ __ ] moment
with like one-on-one on a pass rusher
probably in the Superbowl with Dante
Hightower was probably the craziest one
because I was lined up off the ball is
kind of an h-back and they slid the
protection to the right so no one even
like slowed them down with the hand like
our come up just like all right I'm
about it just wear this one and by the
grace of God my hands got put in the
right spot then he stumbled a little bit
and I felt it definitely got away with
the holding call and then put him on the
ground and immediately you know it's bad
when both players look at the ref thank
god the ref was like I see no evil and
just had his eyes downfield so luckily I
go technically you put down to our into
the earth he put me on my my butt a
couple times earlier in the game so I'll
call that as slightly get one back using
his trip to make it look worse
how how special is Kyle I mean I've you
know been fortunate enough to be around
my third offensive coordinator now and
Dirk cutter I mean I don't know him that
well yet I mean Sark Sark did a good job
for us here a lot of things about Dirk
cutter and I mean just I don't know if
it's because I'm rookie or anything but
or just a success we had but the amount
of football knowledge kyle hadn't the
ability to put specific people in great
positions of success and like
specifically game planning off of like
one or two defenders like he'll be like
I remember game plans to be like this
three technique we're gonna make his day
a living hell and like a simplest thing
bike so so my rookie year we played the
Saints with
a lot of cover to and with cover three
where they bring an eighth guy in the
box there's like look man if they ever
roll up in a seven-man box against us
Devante you better have 150 yards
rushing today all right soon as you go
eight box Julio we're gonna do that play
action drift route across the middle and
you're gonna tell you know simple cues
like Nostradamus man like if he called
it it actually happened it was crazy I
just thought that's what an NFL
offensive coordinator was first season
that's what I'm saying like I just
didn't know and you're like these legs
Wednesday and meetings he was like yeah
we're gonna run this here as soon as I
go eight box and then we're gonna score
I'm just like okay like this probably
coach talk or whatever and then it
actually happen like this guy's
Nostradamus like this guy is a fortune
teller and it would happen every time
and I mean we scored so many points that
year I mean obviously players were
already bought in but like well guys
they're a top ten off and the guys
shooting 90% at the free-throw line like
you tend to believe he's gonna make it
so I mean we just dream is getting off
tevin's getting off Julio's having the
season Mohammed was eating yeah got a
couple other receivers who came in there
driving he wasn't with us know who was
the guy who was your slot guy that ran a
million miles an hour I got a big
contract I talked about Taylor Taylor
Gabriel thank you yeah
Thomas Benjamin and Taylor Gabriel
Gabriel up until week six then it became
turbo one word just like when Trello a
big game became - yeah I'll just let you
got to be in our receiver room man our
receiver room it has to be it's
incredible you got Julio Muhammad at the
time you had Taylor he was Taylor
Gabriel before he became turbo shoutout
Gabe but yeah that room and with Raheem
Morris as a wide receivers coach it is
absurd Garrett we share we share a wall
tight end room is right here receiver
rooms right here all you hear is just
non-stop laughter yelling screaming but
it's all prop like positive like course
I mean it's not like our receiver room
wasn't productive there's no yeah
there's no reason for Raheem to be a
hard-ass like your receivers you know
arguably had the best receiver room and
all agree I agree so I mean it's like I
don't have to teach these guys how to
run the slant route let me give them
good information came out with turbos go
Gabe did and it oh he self-proclaimed
lame turbo man it was crazy he went full
third person with it sometimes to is
that is there one of my favorite
teammate so I've ever played with is the
the room still amazing by Roberts
incredible we added Calvin Ridley who's
in my opinion the best young receiver in
football
who's the wide receivers coach now cuz I
know it's not it's not Raheem anymore is
it he's still there what's what about
Raheem is he's one of the head coach
receivers coach man defensive back coach
head coach and then flips over a wide
receiver coach and I think a lot of it
was because Kyle was like you you
understand the wide receiver position
better information about defensive backs
and Raheem Morris a guy who coached I'll
sits in the wide receiver with him a lot
right a lot he was the wide out him so
so my theory is that right now the best
play callers in the NFL were former wide
receivers Kyle played wide receiver at
Texas Sean McVeigh played wide receiver
at Miami of Ohio Josh McDaniels played
wide receiver as well and I think and I
think the connection is they know I
think when there's a quarterback that
becomes a play caller they're really
good at knowing what the quarterback
likes like likes and they and
comfortable but when a wide receiver is
the play caller they know how to get
people open and they know how to mess
with defense is where a quarterback is
just going I just want the post clean I
want the corner clean agreed but the
wide receiver coach can gonna go I know
the real holes I know how to get all
these guys going yes the movement the
bunch is what does this guy do really
well for example when Kyle was here
everyone had like I once everybody would
obviously be able to do everything yeah
when it's like third down it's like
Mohamed Sanu is gonna break any one off
in the slot we're gonna give him an
option you have three options but zone
turnaround sip pop easy first down she's
playing inside leverage were come inside
breakout playing outside
give him something outside and go in and
Mohamed was incredible he had to be like
over 90% efficient on that route and he
throws a [ __ ] beautiful deep ball
dude he's nice he's out there in
training camp sometimes tossing it I
think the guy could go Enzo Enzo if you
really want to know you see him bobble
snap off his back foot launch at 62
Julio so I at the Super Bowl
we measured my throw it was cold it was
windy did you have a metric pressure was
probably off - yeah that's probably you
gotta watch out for that how far do you
think I threw it I'd say probably 45
this man looked at my chest did you guys
notice how you looked 49 was that
impressive to you actually is man the
thing is is fell towards your rotator
cuff the next to my [ __ ] arm out so
hard but the thing is when you get on a
football field and you stand at midfield
and you look at the endzone you go
[ __ ] I could do that easy when
somebody stands on the endzone and you
realize the depth perception that's when
you realize how far 55 from the rafters
the foot on the football field looks
real small then you step on you're like
wow these guys are pretty big in this
feels pretty damn long was there which
player the sheer size of them like awed
you like was it like are we talking like
coleus Campbell are we really I looked
at him I was just like it's gonna be one
of those days and he looked at uni he's
your number 81 yeah he goes everyone I
got you
like his voice is insane yeah I know
it's insanity his sanity I just used my
quickness and getting good by session
latch-on not holding latching greatest
tight end ever who's your who's your
number one man grown up watching
watching Tony G I mean he's he's the man
who kind of reinvented the position I
mean there are a lot of great ones
before Shannon Sharpe was a credible you
know one of a kind town in his own right
I mean if you want to go back the old GM
for the Ravens was awesome Kellen
Winslow senior was really phenomenal
you did say Shannon I think Shannon
doesn't get mentioned a lot and I don't
know why well I don't have any not like
he wasn't productive insanely productive
I think the rete like when Gronk retired
everybody was proclaiming him to be the
best and I think it's because the the
stories of him as a blocker added to
what he did is receive he was probably
the best all-around and that's how I
feel like Tony I think was the best you
know who didn't talk about either
Antonio Gates or Jason Witten Jason I
don't think Jason wins at their level
I think jason witten though holland can
you believe he's back what was the NFL
player someone's gonna pay you like that
why not yeah six months of work I'll
tell you could you imagine taking a year
off and then coming back I don't know
why not get your body healthy real quick
and then come right back and do it it's
not like you don't know the kalevi I
don't know the quarterback don't know
the offense and just come in cold the
thing about the Cowboys offense is it's
all read and react it's all run seven
yards and if he invented the Y option
for the most part you happy that half
their offenses I mean could be Coach
Garrett embellishing a little bit down
in at the Pro Bowl but yeah he said it
was like third and seven or less kind of
like much with dirt cutter when he had
Tony G here it's like man just just get
it open right just get open and then his
connection with a Romo you want to
talking about like them building
overtime no yeah are you kidding me like
that he probably a headset in the back
of his ear all right Oh balls are in the
air and he's still at the top of the
stem didn't even pick yet to someone
that doesn't root for the Falcons or the
Saints
how can you explain to me why that
rivalry is so heated I don't think I can
give you good answer man it's it's been
there a long time before I was a part of
this organization growing up on the west
coast I didn't really see it by just
saying exactly that's where I knew
Southern football cities where it's just
like historically that's been like I
mean in New Orleans that's that's a
pride of the city and the other I guess
the other city closest to it I'm you
know don't think them and the Oilers
ever had any he was more just the
Falcons for whatever its I mean the NFC
South has played each other for however
many tech right so and I mean both the
fan bases are known to be pretty did you
realize that the Falcons Saints rivalry
is was real it's another level I knew it
was crazy when my rookie year in 2016 we
played in the Superdome on the 10-year
anniversary of Hurricane Katrina
you want to talk about a loud stadium
hole that was my first time in the
Superdome to just seeing all lights and
it's just like a big room so they make a
pitch black then you see the gold purple
and green lights and then the flames
shoot up start announcing the stars I'm
like it's my third NFL game I'm like
Jesus this is fans are yelling things
oh yeah well hydrated fresh off Bourbon
Street like they're there they're ready
to get after it in the stands so I mean
have you ever been like like I hear a
lot of [ __ ] talkers though like research
people have you ever been researched and
someone came at you with some personal
[ __ ] no I don't think anyone even knows
I play in the NFL so luckily I got more
time before some people take a deep dive
it give me give me the the good and the
bad of being an NFL player and not being
recognized on the street like what's
good and what's bad I can go wherever I
will not yeah and go wherever I want I
mean I'm not gonna be like a [ __ ]
little fans or anything like someone has
something to say wants to take picture
signs yeah of course I always do it was
I I was that little kid of course I mean
I was at the Super Bowl and Tyriq Hill
is on a scooter mm-hmm and I go to my
friend I go that's Tyree killed he goes
no it's not I go I go one of you want
about like a million out of my job yeah
it's like mighty right now but he was
like he's like oh I thought he'd be
bigger that's the thing about NFL
players you ever wash the helmet and
shoulder pads and everything like oh you
don't and not a be on camera which makes
you look even bigger you're like well
you aren't as big as I thought you
weren't TV I'm like that's a huge
compliment thank you yeah exactly I
don't get that I usually get your little
bit bigger than I thought yeah well I've
been eating salads when a comic winter
is going I feel like you're an
inquisitive guy do you have any
questions for me yeah I mean we're
talking off air like how did you get
this whole thing started I was a news
reporter in Hastings Nebraska for two
years as my first job don't apologize
me going to the middle of nowhere was
the best thing that could have happened
to me because I was all my friends were
in New York and they were all partying
and I was like I'm gonna go and I have
to be here for two years
i'ma bust my ass and that's all I
thought about like oh I would just sit
there and be like I'm gonna make like a
DVD and send it to Pittsburgh let me a
DVD so like that kind of I did that for
two years covered goat Fashion Show I
covered city council meetings did all
that [ __ ] shot my own stuff at a
nonsense a purgatory for two years
okay I made you the man you are today
something in the universe I was I was an
[ __ ] so it kind of straightened me
out
then I became a sports anchor in
Louisville Kentucky and I cover a lot of
college basketball
after that I got a job at bleacher
report because I kind of went viral with
some clips where I I dropped like 40 MBA
or 40 Seinfeld references in a show and
then I did one than a week later like 40
rap references so now when you see
people do that they're really pulling a
left go I just got really [ __ ] boy
start hanging up the Guinness World
Records in the back yeah I'm over the
camera can see the world's most world's
douchiest sports guy and then I got a
job at bleacher report and I've been
there for five years man I would me and
me and Sims would do like 40 videos a
day and nobody would see them because
this was back when the app wasn't as
popular and like I do one Falcons video
one Giants video and now after a while
we kind of launch the podcast and just
kept doing it and I honestly think that
patience is the virtue you know and I
mean and you you you you don't realize
what you're accomplishing until you look
up like a year or two later look at Joe
Rogan he didn't start up I literally
just said beforehand that people look at
Joe Rogan now and they don't realize
he's been doing this for like ten years
yeah like it's maybe him on a couch yes
like in his living room and now he has
like a full studio with like
professional everything and it's all I
have so many people now that are hitting
me up that are like I'm thinking about
starting a podcast you're a little too
late and because it's fun you know it's
like this out it's it's TV but it's
relaxed and and it's we live in my mind
in an on-demand society where you're
gonna go and if you if you're not there
to watch Game of Thrones right away
you'll watch it when you can watch it in
gratification and so podcast I think
fits perfectly into our it can be
clipped up for social media for
Instagram Twitter and all that but also
if I watch you on the local news I'm
gonna get 15 seconds of you
mmm-hmm you're a funny guy I've never
met you before
a podcast you get to be in front of my
audience the homies through from the FCC
airwaves either right right I'll just be
you yeah so this has fit me well too cuz
I'm a goon and podcasting is good for
goons you know what I mean yeah it's
your product they can't tell you how to
censor it all right let me ask you now
I'm gonna ask you a question if you're a
baseball player what would your walk-up
song be mmm rubberband man ci while does
the Taliban not in my right 45 in my
other hand this man knows his stuff that
was that I had a big TI stage there was
a moment there was a fail oh it was like
right when I was pledging a fraternity
in college so I was like I have to get
through this and Ti is gonna be like my
mantra Patton 36 and all of them that
got you through law so Bo I thought
you'd be listening to like some Cali I
think I listened to Red Hot Chili
Peppers on Reed looks like a 40 or some
[ __ ] course Mac Dre 40 bumming so that
came to south like I learned about a lot
of people that I never heard of like fat
Pat and listen to starting a lot more
you know southern stuff I mean like my
rookie years when a amigos put out
culture and luckily Julio's been a like
the fourth amigo sometimes yeah so we
were lucky enough to hear in the locker
room a little bit before everyone else
did we were just like splash you're like
I was like what is happening but I don't
know what it means but it sounds good
that's a minute
yeah it was awesome the first time this
will be this is my official last
question you're gonna have to come on
again you're good man I got nothing
going on the first time you saw the
athletic freak that Julio is was when
it's hard man cuz after a while you
become so desensitized that's the thing
about great players in the NFL is we
don't even talk about it but when you
saw him whether it was camper a workout
or a route I would say my rookie year he
ran this thing called a a take off so
what you do is you sell it to see how we
brought amigos all together
now the fourth amigos always has
something some references in their quavo
go deep anyway so let's take off right
so you run like a 20 yard come back it's
a double move though so come back show
your hips and eyes and then turn around
and immediately sprint which is
phenomenal because it's hard to go when
do you it's definitely that'll speed
like when there's a quarterback ever
going
we just went 20 yards and now he's doing
a comeback this is a thousand percent
the end with a nine man protection how
much time does this guy have right there
yeah now so I saw him run you know 21
miles an hour take three steps to stop
just like a guy yeah which is incredible
in itself turns around gets a DB coming
downhill eyes looking for the to jump to
come back so he did it he plays with
defenders to to let them he he directs
them basically so he showed it enough to
trigger the in the DBS Monica's ran
comebacks earlier in practice alright so
come back so he lets him get in his
pocket turns around and puts his right
foot in the ground puts his head down
and runs then he takes a peek see the
balls thrown far I've never seen anyone
do this sees the ball says okay puts his
head back down and run get back into a
full phase and then picks his head up
this right there I've never seen
anything like that cuz like other guys
who aren't as good like me like your
eyes are just staring in your trench I
can't run I can't mate who is like
that's a little far just like a
centerfielder
alright let me put my head back down I'm
tracking the ball without even looking
at it and then look up BAM it's right
there I was just like in that moment I'm
like that is Julio Jones also I feel
like you probably looked around the
sideline we're like holy shame thing
right and guys are just like yeah it's
just it's Wednesday dude calm down
dams like what what and like when other
guys from other teams come on the same
thing right they're like did you see we
just did I'm like what just ran by two
people and jumped over to other people
and caught him like yeah they're like
what that's not special to you and I'll
just I thought about for a second same
thing I was like you're officially that
guy does yeah I'm just like I guess
after a while you become so desensitized
to you just don't even understand
because I'm Cowboys game they literally
doubled him this was what two years ago
now the guy was we cooked player
backside Julio's in the slot over here
so he's already has 20 yards in front of
him the Safety's coming down to Dublin
so they're kind of like you know bracket
him in that way
he runs by both of them that perfect
angle runs by both them and catches the
ball on the far sideline and same
linebacker his sight dude did you see
that I'm like yes third down we went to
Julio like what's up the thing about
Julio is - I've made many arguments the
last few years I think Odell's the best
receiver because I think he has a
top-end speed that is really really
scary I've been making a lot of
arguments lately that I would put Tyreke
as the the scariest of them so close but
when you look at the last few years and
you realize that Julio is one or two
every year in receiving yards and you
know that they're targeting all the time
and you think of the physical elements
the fact that he's not the highest-paid
wide receiver in the NFL is kind of
crazy it's a little crazy yeah I'm not
going to speak on the money side as much
but I mean you can say that your
teammates a hundred percent think
Julio's worth every single penny like
the he's I do realize though that I feel
like Julio getting a new contract has
been like a news story for a few years I
mean as his teammate like I wanted to
see him get paid what he's worth but I
same time you know I'm not I'm not in
front office I have no control over what
happens I'm just you know supporting him
luckily the salary cap keeps going but
going back to your point about an
instant gratification society like
Julio's not on social media you won't
hear one controversial thing you won't
hear one bad tidbit in the media like if
if a game ends because he did whatever
like he'll be a man's show to me to be
like you know it this was on me like
you'll never hear anything
you will never throw anyone under the
bus you won't say anything dumb and like
like most reports they'll try to get you
and who sticks come under the wide
receiver table though I don't know man
God do something if that's the worst
thing you can get on him then yeah he
doesn't say God bless you and somebody
sneezed probably that Julio you knew
whatever yeah yeah
a bad guy yeah what an [ __ ] yes I
think that's the thing my fuse my folio
because I want to call them either
Julio Holmes or Giulio Jones it just
throws me off that the Jay is completely
different in both names no yeah if he
wasn't I like Julio Hong's gone full
South American with it ya like it Polly
a holidays bonus it was a pleasure to
meet you thank you problem had a great
[ __ ] time me too that was it we fixed
it yeah we we got it at the end where do
you spend your offseasons Atlanta
probably you can do the matt ryan thing
again are you working out let's waste up
on the beginning I'm a beaver down there
and SoCal with them and get to get my
tan going hang out on the beach and run
some routes so be a hopefully be pre
relaxing before a camping season gets
going if I had to do like subtitles for
this podcast for the podcast it would be
Austin Hooper and then what what line
did you just say on the beach get my tan
get my tan on and running routes that's
what your book title should be put that
on my gravestone beautiful